excuse me sir you dropped your wallet
sir
I identify as a woman get on the ground
you misgendering people sir put your
hands behind your back right now sir
no I'm a woman yeah I'm gonna need you
to put your hands behind your back yep I
also get that man right there man
[Music]
I meant to say woman that's that's what
I meant identify as a thing
[Music]
yup officer get that that person person
no I now identify as a chair
yeah
officer yeah
the best part of the video is the
complete lack of production value he
didn't even get a fake gun to be holding
because that's the whole point you don't
need to have a gun you don't need to
have a costume you don't need to change
your voice you don't need to do anything
you can just be whatever you want